- As I have for every movie
in the "Chucky" franchise,
I'm gonna go over everything
you might've missed
in season one of "Chucky".
With eight episodes,
there's a lot to cover.
So let's start at the beginning
with the opening title sequence.
Each episode has a unique title animation
that plays over the theme song.
And this theme song may sound familiar,
because it's actually a
re-orchestrated version
of a track from the original
score for "Child's Play 2".
Let me play them both for comparison.
Here's the theme from the show.
(sinister music)
And here's a clip from "Child's Play 2".
I'll take out the dialogue
so you can just focus on the music.
(slow sinister music)
Choosing a track from "Child's Play 2"
lets the viewer know that this season
is a tribute to that second movie.
The season features more
elements of "Child's Play 2"
than we've seen since,
well, "Child's Play 2".
Just as "Curse of Chucky"
was a sort of second coming
of the first "Child's Play",
"Chucky" season one would
be a sort of second coming
of its sequel.
Not only is the story very similar,
"Child's Play 2" is about
Andy going to a foster home
where he's hunted by Chucky
and "Chucky" season one
is about Jake Wheeler
receiving foster care
from his aunt and uncle
after his dad is electrocuted by Chucky,
but the visual design of the show
also calls back to that 1990 sequel.
- Chucky's look, we've
taken a lot of pains
to mimic the specific
look of the doll himself
from "Child's Play 2".
I was just talking to someone who said,
"It's the creepiest version,
but weirdly also the cutest."
- [Zac] In this feature,
series creator Don Mancini
explains why he chose the second movie
as an inspiration for the series.
- I've heard over the years from fans
telling me that "Child's
Play 2" is their favorite.
Now, with the TV series, it
was the perfect opportunity
to dig into where those
characters are now 30 years on.
- This was the first time
we got to see Andy and Kyle
work together since then.
And the show even uses
their original actors,
Alex Vincent and Christine Elise.
Kyle even brings back her
signature hatch from that movie.
There are many, many more parallels
and Easter eggs I can point out.
So let's go through the series
and explore all of its secrets.
To learn about the meaning
behind the advertisements at the school,
how Halloween decorations
foreshadow specific deaths,
who this realtor really is,
the significance of every
name on these tombstones,
and so much more.
Stick around to the end of this video.
(dark rock music)
Welcome to "Things You Missed".
They say you can't keep a good guy down.
A lot of times when a
series gets a reboot,
fans have to say goodbye
to any hopes of revisiting
the original continuity.
The Chucky franchise got that reboot
with "Child's Play" in 2019,
but the original voodoo-powered Chucky
was not ready to give up the spotlight.
Don Mancini, who has
been with this franchise
since the beginning, had
been doing some work in TV
on the show "Hannibal"
and was inspired to try "Chucky"
as a weekly show as well.
Now, instead of an 80-minute movie,
we have a six-hour season to analyze,
which means there's more room
for a ton of things you missed.
Let's get into them.
(sword scrapes)
(sinister music)
The series opens with this POV shot
of the young Charles Lee Ray
going upstairs and seeing his
mother combining your hair.
This is the first of many homages
to the "Halloween" franchise.
The original "Halloween" opens with a POV
of the young Michael Myers going upstairs
and seeing his sister combining her hair
in the exact same fashion.
We've seen "Chucky" films steal
"Halloween" openings before.
"Seed of Chucky" has pretty
much the same opening
and "Cult of Chucky" has a
psychiatric patient transfer
at the beginning, much like
several "Halloween" movies.
So there are always a lot
of "Halloween" references
in Chucky movies.
Just because Michael Myers
is like a supernatural
slasher forefather to Chucky.
But this time, there
are even more than usual
because the series takes
place around Halloween.
By the way, can you guess
the only other Chucky film
to take place in October?
It's "Child's Play 2".
Another "Halloween" reference
is the inclusion of a
character named Dr. Mixter.
This brings to mind the
doctor from "Halloween II".
- [Woman] Try to relax, Laurie.
Dr. Mixter will have you
stitched up in no time.
- I'm sure it's no mistake
that when we first hear Dr. Mixter's name
brought up by Lexy's mom,
she's actually speaking
about Halloween, the holiday.
- Besides Dr. Mixter says
that Halloween is the perfect opportunity
for you girls to bond.
- By the way, this is not the first time
that we've seen a Chucky character
named after a Halloween character.
In "Child's Play 3", we
met Colonel Cochrane,
who was named after Colonel
Cochrane from "Halloween III".
I may have neglected to mention that
in my "Child's Play 3" video.
Another parallel can
be seen in episode two,
where we see a flashback
to Charles Lee Ray in 1965
where he dresses up as
a clown for Halloween.
In the movie "Halloween",
Michael Myers also dresses up as a clown
for a Halloween night in the 1960s.
In that same scene, we see
Charles bite into an apple
with a razor in it.
A kid in "Halloween II"
does the same thing.
I'll note that this
might not be a reference
to the "Halloween II" kid.
It could just be about the urban legend
that the "Halloween II" kid is based on.
It's the same thing with
Lexy and her sister.
Lexy has plans on Halloween night,
but her parents tell her
that they're going out
so she has to babysit
Caroline and she's annoyed.
I found myself wondering
if this is supposed to be a
reference to "Halloween 4",
where Rachel Carruthers
is forced to babysit
her adoptive sister Jamie
while her parents go
out on Halloween night,
thus ruining her plans for the evening.
There might be another
"Halloween" connection
involving Lexy and her
sister the next night
when she's putting Caroline down to bed
and Caroline asks her to sing a lullaby.
- Bedtime. You have to sing to me.
- So Lexy sings "Don't Fear the Reaper"
by Blue Oyster Cult,
the same song that Laurie
and Annie listened to
in the car in "Halloween 1".
And as much as I like the song,
I'm getting pretty tired of
hearing it in movies and TV.
We already heard it in
"Halloween", "Zombieland",
"Gone Girl", and "Scream".
And that's just covering the movies
that I analyzed here
on "Things You Missed".
Forget the other 76 productions
that it's been in so far,
according to IMDB.
In the flashback where we see the death
of Charles Lee Ray's parents,
his mom tries to hide him
in a shuttered closet,
just like the one that
Laurie Strode hides in
in "Halloween".
And in episode four,
Chucky terrorizes the
Hackensack Memorial Hospital,
which is abbreviated to HMH,
just like the Haddonfield
Memorial Hospital
from "Halloween II" and "Halloween Kills".
Later on, "Halloween's" final
girl comes up in a discussion
between Devon and Jake
about horror movies.
- Favorite final girl?
- Laurie Strode hands down.
- Jamie Lee's gonna win
the Saturn this year.
- Dude, she's gonna win an Oscar.
She's magnificent.
- Spoiler alert: Jamie Lee
Curtis did not win an Oscar
for "Halloween Kills".
At the time of recording this video,
the Saturn Awards have
not yet taken place.
Shortly after this conversation,
Chucky breaks into the
house and kills the lights,
something that Michael
Myers is known for doing.
And finally, we have Andy and Kyle
stopping at an auto
repair shop/gas station
and Andy strands her
there for her own good.
Michael Myers strands Dr. Loomis
at an auto repair/gas
station in "Halloween 4".
And that is not the end of this video.
That's just the end of the
"Halloween" references.
So let's get back to the
beginning of the series
when Jake is first buying
Chucky at the yard sale.
According to this video with Don Mancini,
this is actually Tiffany
crossing through right here.
She wears this red coat
later in the season
so she's probably checking in
to make sure that an innocent,
like Jake, is the one who
ends up with the doll.
When Jake walks home from the yard sale,
there are a couple more
Easter eggs on the podcast
that he's listening to.
(sinister music)
(thunder rumbles)
(sinister electronic music)
Jake is listening to Devon's
podcast "Hackenslash",
which, according to this graphic,
posts new episodes every Tuesday.
The "Chucky" series also release
new episodes on Tuesdays.
We can see that Jake is
currently on episode eight.
"Chucky" season one is
an eight episode season.
As Devon explains the morbid
history of Hackensack,
we see graphics on screen
that go along with what he's saying.
This one, which appears
for just one moment,
is the same article on
the Lakeshore Strangler
that Tiffany kept in her
trailer in "Bride of Chucky".
Shortly after that,
there's another article
which appears to be from a
website written by Ethan Carson.
This article appears
again in episode seven
on Devon's corkboard.
This is our first crew
reference Easter egg.
Ethan Carson is the art
department assistant.
Then after 56 seconds, the podcast ends.
That was a short podcast.
Jake goes home and we see his room.
He's got a poster for a
band called Mad Ashes.
This might be a clue of things to come.
Later on, we see Chucky
return with a vengeance
after surviving a fire.
And similarly, we see Andy's wrath
after escaping from an explosion.
We also meet Jake's cat, Banksy.
- Banskys.
Here, Banks.
- Banksy is an artist known
for his street murals,
but he's also worked
in many other mediums,
like Jake's forte sculpting.
When Banksy bites the dust,
so does Jake's sculpture.
The next day, Jake brings Chucky to school
and he's picked on by a classmate
named Oliver Hayden on the bus.
Oliver throws a pair of
gym shorts in his face.
That's a pretty hostile thing to do
and it reminds me a lot of
the extremely hostile kid
on the bus in "Child's Play 2",
which, if you watch my channel,
you know I always, always,
always have to bring up.
Why are you so hostile?
Oliver is also wearing yellow,
so he matches the kid that
was throwing stuff on the bus
in "Child's Play 2".
Just because this season is
themed around the second film,
that doesn't mean that each of
the others isn't referenced.
In the cafeteria at school,
there's an advertisement
for a hearty bowl of chili,
the same meal that the Pierce family eats
in the famous chili scene
from "Curse of Chucky".
- I love chili.
- This is amazing.
- I can't believe there's no meat in this.
And it's so hearty.
- Speaking of not having meats,
the banner also advertises
a beyond meat burger.
That might be the scariest
thing of this whole episode.
The drinks being served
are a bright red punch,
'cause there's gonna be blood.
When Devon sits by Jake and
asks what he's watching.
Jake says that he's watching
"The Vampire Diaries".
Now I haven't seen "The Vampire Diaries",
but this Reddit post from cesardaniel02
talks about how there
are a lot of similarities
between the two series.
Both are part of this teen horror genre
with an expanding network of villains.
Vampires can turn people
into fellow vampires
to grow their ranks,
and Chucky can possess dolls
or people to grow his ranks.
The post also talks about similarities
between the characters
like Jake and Jeremy,
such as how both lose their parents.
I'll link the post in the description
if you want to read further.
After receiving a call from Andy Barclay,
warning him about Chucky,
Jake looks up Good Guy Doll violence
on a search engine called Search.
If you've been keeping up
with my Chucky episodes,
then you're already familiar
with the strange handling
of website brand names
in the world of Chucky.
For example, Curse is careful to specify
that Nica uses "Internet
Search" instead of Google.
But one movie later, in
Cult, Andy namedrops Google.
The series has similar inconsistencies.
Chucky stalks Lexy on a social media site
called SquarePix,
but later on specifically uses the words--
- Instagram influencers.
- There's even a joke
where the kids try to find
Andy Barclay on social media
by searching Insta, Snap, and Twitter
and then Devon eventually
finds him on Facebook
and he's laughing
'cause of course the old
person would be on Facebook.
They should've checked there first.
- [Devon] Hey, Lexy. He's on Facebook.
- Anyway, as Jake is looking
into the Chucky dolls
passed on Search, each of the
results references an incident
from a previous Chucky movie.
The first four are from "Child's Play".
The headlines read, "six-year-old
boy says Chucky did it,"
which is Andy, "Urban legends:
Charles Lee Ray and Chucky,
Boy's Babysitter Dies in Freak Accident,"
which is Aunt Maggie,
and "Explosion on South
Side Leaves One Dead,"
which is Eddie Caputo.
(gun fires)
(house explodes)
The next one is about the
teacher from "Child's Play 2"
and we get a new piece of information.
We've always known that Andy's
teacher was Miss Kettlewell,
but for the first time they
reveal her first name Elizabeth.
The last results talks
about the Play Pal CEO
from "Child's Play 2"
and "3", Mr. Sullivan.
And we learned his first
name as well Haskell.
You hear that?
That's the sound of
Wiki pages being updated
across the internet.
Jake confirms that his doll is alive,
the same way that Karen
Barclay did in the first movie:
by discovering that he's been
able to talk without batteries.
His response is to throw
Chucky in the trash.
What the hell is that gonna do
when you already know he's alive?
I think this shot is here
more for the sake of keeping
up with the tradition
of characters throwing
Chucky in the trash.
Kyle does it in 2, Colonel
Cochrane does it in 3,
Sarah does it in Curse,
Claire does it in Cult,
Andy does it in the
remake, and in episode five
Lexy's dad also attempts to
throw Chucky in the trash.
Obviously Jake trashing
his doll doesn't work
and he appears shortly thereafter
at the school talent show.
- I see some familiar
faces in the crowd tonight.
- [Zac] From this line, we cut
to a shot of Lexy's family.
And indeed, there is
a familiar face there,
because her father is played by an actor
named Michael Therriault,
who also played Dr. Foley
in the previous installment
"Cult of Chucky".
The split screen editing
technique in this scene
is also something that
was taken from Cult.
Speaking of familiar faces,
there are a lot of repeats in the crowd.
A lot of doppelgangers
in Hackensack, I guess.
They might have been low on extras
or maybe this was some
kind of COVID precaution.
Chucky makes it appear
as if Jake is performing
a ventriloquist act on stage.
This is the same trick used by Glen
at the beginning of "Seed of Chucky".
That night, the power goes out in a storm
and Jake's dad goes to the
basement to use the breaker box.
We're shown to this shot of a
spider web in the foreground.
It's the first shot we
see of Jake's basement
and it's just like the first
shot we see of the attic
in "Curse of Chucky" and "Seed of Chucky",
both of which also have us
looking through a spider web.
The first episode ends
with the first onscreen
kill of the series,
which is Jake's dad, Lucas
Wheeler getting electrocuted.
Remember how I said this
series has an emphasis
on "Child's Play 2"?
Well, an electrocution
is also the first death
in that movie.
Because he's now an orphan,
Jake would be moved into
his aunt and uncle's house,
which contains many
more things you missed.
- And now a word from our sponsors.
(sinister music)
(ominous music)
- When Jake Wheeler finally
has a moment to himself again,
he has a lot of questions
for his retro doll.
- Talk to me.
I said talk to me, damn it!
- It's almost the same
line that Andy's mom
confronted the Chucky doll
with in "Child's Play".
- Say something, damn it!
- We next see Jake a
week later on Halloween.
He and his cousin, Junior,
get home from school
and Junior's having some trouble
with the security system.
It turns out that Junior's
dad changed the code
and Jake lets him know.
Junior is essentially
no longer the only child
and he feels a sense
of jealousy as a result
and this fuels the rivalry between them.
The tension between the two boys
builds throughout the episode
and it eventually leads
to Mr. and Mrs. Wheeler
sitting down to discuss if
it's actually a good idea
to look after Jake.
Can we just pause it here?
If you're a parent, take note,
this is a terrible place to
have a secret conversation.
- He's not a violent kid.
He's just traumatized.
- We're all traumatized.
I mean, are we even qualified
to look after a boy like this?
- [Zac] This is the exact same situation
that Andy's caretakers found themselves in
after taking him in in "Child's Play 2".
- Are we even qualified to
take care of a boy like this?
- And they later have
a conversation about it
that is also eavesdropped upon.
- You have to admit, he's
a very troubled little boy.
I mean, obviously he's not come to terms
with this whole doll thing.
- Going forward, the
Wheeler house would become
the main location in the series.
It would be the stage for three deaths
and one additional funeral.
And the cherry blossom
designs all over the walls
serve as a symbol for this.
They almost look like splatters of blood
sprayed upon the walls.
It's also fitting that
they have four skeletons
on display for Halloween,
representing the four
members of the family
who would die this season.
Bree, Logan, and Junior,
and the maid Annie.
- Annie really was a part of this family.
- [Zac] The ones in the middle
are a couple, Bree and Logan,
which are the middle two
deaths chronologically.
Jake confronts Chucky about Annie's death,
but Chucky denies the allegation.
- Swear to God, I didn't kill her.
- However, if you've seen Curse,
you know that swearing to
God means nothing to Chucky.
- There is no God.
- [Zac] Chucky tries to convince Jake
with an offer of friendship.
- I'm your friend to the end.
- F*ck with that sh*t.
I'm not six years old.
- That's a reference to "Child's Play" one
which takes place on
Andy's sixth birthday.
- We're friends to the end, remember?
- Chucky's manipulation tactics continue
as he tries to relate to
Jake using his sexuality.
- You know, I have a queer kid.
- You have a kid?
- Chucky seems to be talking
about Glen and Glenda
from "Seed of Chucky".
If you haven't seen Seed,
it's about Chucky and Tiffany's
child who is born as a doll
and thus has no private parts.
So Chucky and Tiffany argue
about if it's a boy or a girl
causing the kid to switch
between the two identities,
Glen and Glenda.
We haven't seen Glen or Glenda since then,
but I'm guessing switching
between the two alter egos
may have caused the
grown up Glen and Glenda
to be considered by bisexual,
which is probably what
Chucky is referencing here.
Glenda actually gets a second
reference in episode eight.
- [Junior] What's that?
- Isn't it cute?
My darling Glenda gave it to me.
They have exquisite taste.
- [Zac] Meanwhile, over at Lexy's house,
Caroline has developed
an obsession with Chucky
ever since seeing him
insult her older sister
at the talent show.
There's no way in hell a little
kid could draw this well,
but the whole thing reminds me of Madeline
from "Cult of Chucky", who also
became attached to the doll
and started sketching pictures of him.
- [Mr. Cross] Baby, can
you remember his name?
- [Caroline] Chucky.
- (chuckles) Yes, that's right.
- That might be the
dumbest thing I've heard.
You think she can remember and reproduce
every little detail about him,
including the text on his pocket
yet she wouldn't be able
to remember his name?
What the hell is wrong with you?
Why would you ask that?
Can you remember his name?
That evening, Devon's mom breaks the news
about what happened to Annie.
Devon is a true crime buff
and his room is decorated
with news clippings
about famous criminals.
He seems to have a particular
interest in the Zodiac case.
I covered "Zodiac" here
on Things You Missed
and one of the things I
mentioned in that movie
was how they used real
newspaper clippings in the film
to make everything look
as authentic as possible.
Perhaps as an homage,
the same is done here.
Some of the other true crime
cases that he has on display
are real articles as well.
Despite Annie's untimely death,
Junior still decides to go over
to Oliver's Halloween party.
When his ride pulls up,
there's a cameo appearance
from Don Mancini as the Uber driver.
It's hard to tell if it's him,
but he confirmed on Twitter.
When we arrive on the
scene of Oliver's party,
it's gotta be the most
lit middle school party
in the history of the world.
When I was in middle school,
I don't remember any of my classmates
pulling up in a Maserati.
I mean, I've been to parties
thrown by some of the biggest YouTubers
and even those are not on this level.
Except for my party.
My party was the greatest.
(metal music)
♪ Ahem. ♪
♪ EVERYBODY'S OUT TO GET ME! ♪
- [Wavywebsurf] Oh my, what the f--
- There are at least
three kids at this party
dressed up in army gear.
The third movie takes place
at a military academy.
Away from the action,
Chucky and Caroline have
already made friends
and Chucky has already
begun to try to convince her
to kill her sister.
- Mommy says real killing is bad.
- Yeah, well mommy's full of sh**.
- Mommy says it isn't nice to swear.
- Mommy's working her way up
my list pretty ****ing quick.
- If you're keeping counts at home,
this is now the third
child that has taken issue
with Chucky's colorful vocabulary.
- Charles, stop swearing.
- Chucky, stop cursing.
- We actually see
that Chucky first began
teaching profanity to children
as a 14-year-old when he was
staying at the foster home
for wayward boys.
- How was the story, boys?
- ****ing Fantastic.
- Language, young man.
Where did you learn that?
- When Jake realizes
that Chucky is missing,
he rushes to the party.
But before he finds what he's looking for,
the crowd throws him
into a closet with Devon.
There's a false scare
with the little mannequin
wearing a hockey mask,
maybe a reference to Jason
from "Friday the 13th".
Before he's able to find Chucky,
Jake comes across this horrific scene
where Lexy impersonates
his father's death.
I don't really know how she
figured out all of these details
about what he was wearing,
how he died and exactly
what it all looked like
when Mr. Wheeler met his fate
since the only one there
to witness Lucas's death,
other than Jake, was Chucky himself.
But in the next episode,
the creators of the show
would include a ton of jabs
at one Disney franchise
that has been in a long rivalry
with "Child's Play" and "Chucky".
(sinister music)
(thunder claps)
(thunder rumbles)
By the third episode,
Chucky has convinced Jake to kill Lexy.
Well, I guess Lexy did most
of the convincing herself.
He tracks her phone and plans to jump her
while she's jogging in
the middle of the woods.
But it turns out to be Junior,
who had grabbed Lexy's phone
and apparently went on a run with it
instead of just giving
it back to her first.
- Hey, babe.
Oh, thanks for grabbing it.
- And also, they are conveniently
wearing matching hoodies.
This is all clearly done
just to trick the audience,
which I'm never a fan of.
However, the matching
outfits do act as a barometer
for their relationship going forward.
At this point early in the third episode,
Junior and Lexy are really close
because they're both kind of united
in their disdain of Jake.
But at the end of the episode,
Lexy learns that Chucky is
alive and trying to kill her.
So she's forced a team
up with Jake and Devon,
causing her and Junior to drift apart.
By episode six, Junior feels
that she has abandoned him
and he is thinking about
breaking up with her.
In the breakup scene, Junior
is wearing his matching hoodie
but Lexy is not, a sign that
they're no longer in sync
as they once were.
We can also see this in the
way that the scene is shot.
The wide lens emphasizes
the distance between them.
And Junior leaves
towards the most destroyed
part of the house.
He's going down a dark path,
leaving Lexy alone in the
middle to choose her direction.
Chucky continues to try to manipulate Jake
into becoming a killer.
He taunts him for having missed
his chance to take out Lexy.
- It's called completion anxiety.
- Avid Chucky fans may remember
where Chucky first learned
about completion anxiety.
It was from Nica,
who had written her
college thesis on the topic
and used it to get under
his skin back in Curse.
- So you never actually
killed Andy Barclay, did you?
- What?
- It's called completion anxiety.
It's very common in males.
- Jake does end up relenting
and giving the doll to Lexy,
who uses it to appease her sister.
I don't get why the parents are acting
like a child's playing with a toy
in the most normal way possible
as some kind of breathtaking thing.
- Great, what's the
little genius doing now?
- Ssh, look.
- I don't get it.
She's just playing with
a toy like any kid would.
Caroline's supposed age is
put even more into question
later that day when Lexy
finds her watching TV.
- I thought you're watching "Westworld"?
- Yeah, because Caroline
would absolutely be watching
a very adult-oriented
show like "Westworld".
This line is obviously here,
not because it makes sense in context,
but because the creators wanted once again
to shout-out a show that shares
similarities with Chucky.
Chucky is essentially an animatronic toy
that goes on a rampage.
"Westworld" is about animatronic humanoids
that go on a rampage.
Junior also brings up
"Westworld" in episode five.
- It's a crazy theme park
with these hot robots
and you can, like, do
anything you want to them.
- Though, it's kind of unclear to me
if the creators of Chucky
are fans of "Westworld"
or if they're trying to make fun of it,
because apparently Chucky says
that life is too short to watch it.
- [Caroline] Chucky says life's too short.
He wants to watch the news.
- That's very familiar to
the first "Child's Play",
where Chucky tells Andy
that he wants to watch
the nine o'clock news so that
he can listen for updates
about his former accomplice Eddie Caputo.
In the case of the TV series,
he's probably keeping his eyes peeled
for stories about Andy Barclay,
who was recently found to have escaped
Harrogate Psychiatric Hospital.
It seems like whenever Chucky
is attached to a new kid,
he brings out his usual bag of tricks
because there's also a line
where Caroline says something horrible
and blames it on Chucky.
- I didn't say it. Chucky did.
- We've heard that before in
"Child's Play" and in "Curse".
That is the original "Child's
Play", not to the 2019 remake.
You've probably noticed that
there aren't many connections
to the 2019 "Child's Play",
and that's because it's
essentially a different series.
It's a fresh continuity.
However, it did play a big role
in a long-standing battle
between the "Chucky" franchise
and the "Toy Story" franchise.
"Toy Story" is an animated
film about a kid named Andy
whose toys come to life.
Obviously the similarities
pretty much end there,
but I don't think the
producers of "Chucky"
particularly liked the fact
that the two franchises
share that similarity.
If you're curious, no.
Andy from "Toy Story"
was not an intentional
"Child's Play" reference.
I guess one of the
original Pixar employees
had a son named Andy.
But that didn't stop
Chucky from firing back
during the marketing
campaign for the remake,
which was coming out the same weekend
as "Toy Story 4".
Interestingly, "Chucky" season one
keeps the rivalry alive,
not with Andy, though,
but with Chucky.
In a flashback to his childhood,
we see the inside of his room.
Like Andy in "Toy Story",
he has a combination of
astronaut and cowboy stuff.
The hat hanging on his wall
is Jesse's hat from "Toy Story 2".
He has a View-Master on his nightstand.
The View-Master is a
character in "Toy Story".
And he's got little green
army men on his dresser.
Also characters from "Toy Story".
When we flashback to
present, Lexy senses danger
and she notices Chucky's feet
poking out from under the window curtain.
We've seen this once
before in "Cult of Chucky",
but this time it's only a decoy,
allowing him to sneak up
and make an attempt on her.
It's nice that the series
offers a couple of new twists
rather than just constantly
repeating moments
that we've already seen
in the original seven Chucky movies.
The last thing we see from that night
is the headstone of Charles Lee Ray,
confirming that Jake's dad was indeed
buried in the same graveyard
we were first introduced to
in "Bride of Chucky",
although it looks different
than it did back then.
My theory is maybe the
original got vandalized
and they had to replace it.
- [Man] Why do they do it?
Goddamn kids.
- [Zac] Episode four begins
at Hackensack Hospital,
where many characters are recovering
after Chucky started a
fire at Lexy's party.
For some reason, it seems
like everyone is being treated
besides Lexy herself, which
doesn't make sense to me
because she was closest
to where the fire started.
You would think if anyone got
bronchitis, it would be her.
But I suppose she did
not have time fo dat.
- [Jake] Look, anyone who's
told the truth about Chucky
is either been put away or worse.
Mostly worse.
- Just for fun, let's review.
Who has told the truth about
Chucky and were they put away?
- Andy Barclay, put away.
Karen Barclay, put away.
Lieutenant Preston, dead.
Jesse and Jade Miller,
alive as far as we know.
Jennifer Tilly, supernaturally possessed.
Nica Pierce, put away, then
supernaturally possessed.
I'll assume that Kyle, Ronald Tyler,
and Kristen DeSilva kept their mouth shut
despite knowing about Chucky.
Meanwhile, Devon's mom pays him a visit.
- I'm a mom.
I'll be worried the rest of my life.
- [Zac] Technically true.
Afterwards, Jake is waiting
for Devon in the hallway
when a pink soccer ball
is kicked in his direction
from seemingly no one.
Naturally, being me, CZsWorld,
I thought about "The Shining"
when Danny Torrance is
playing in the hallway
of the Overlook Hotel
and a pink ball mysteriously
rolled up to him.
At first I wasn't sure
if they were trying to
reference "The Shining" here,
but I'm pretty sure it is intentional
because there are a lot
more "Shining" references
throughout the season.
For example, when Tiffany and
Chucky first moved to Chicago
in the flashback, their
room number is Room 237,
which is the most haunted
room in the 1980 movie version
of "The Shining".
When Chucky breaks into Lexy's house,
he drops his own take on the
famous "Here's Johnny" line.
- Here's Chucky.
- A line that he almost said in Seed,
but couldn't think of anything to say.
- I can't think of a thing to say.
- And in episode eight,
when the army of Chucky's
is asking the main Chucky
about which children
are acceptable to kill,
one of them asks--
- What about twins?
- "The Shining" is famous for
showing the graphic mutilation
of a creepy set of twins,
and this is immediately
followed up with Chucky laughing
as we hear the main
theme of "The Shining".
(laughs sardonically)
("The Shining" music)
We hear more music from "The
Shining" during the next scene
when the army of dolls
is being loaded into the back of a truck.
But before we get there,
there is an interesting detail
on the badges of the employees
at the Hackensack Memorial Hospital.
(text thuds)
(sinister music)
Given that his mom is
part of the police force,
Devon finds out that one of
the victims at the party,
Oliver didn't die in the fire.
He was actually stabbed to death.
- Either way there's a
killer out there right now
running around Hackensack.
- [Zac] This is the face of a
kid with a true crime podcast,
trying to act like he's
not excited by that.
The doctors have to perform
a bronchoscopy on Junior.
And I noticed that the badges
worn by the medical staff looked familiar.
They used the same layout
as the badges from the
psychiatric hospital
in "Cult of Chucky".
I doubt that's something
we're even supposed to notice.
It's probably just as simple
as they had leftover props
and storage somewhere,
but I like that it makes
the world feel cohesive
so I'm including it in
my already long video.
To calm his nerves,
Junior sings "We Got the
Beat" by The Go-Go's.
Funny how all these Gen Z
middle school kids in 2021
love all this pop culture stuff
from the '70s, '80s, and '90s,
and in some cases even older stuff.
I already mentioned Lexy singing
Blue Oyster Cult's 1976 hit,
Devon watches "Cape Fear" from 1991,
Jake has a poster from the '80s movie
"The Outsiders" in his room,
the mayor plans to donate Good Guy dolls
to children in need.
What kid is gonna be excited
about a 33-year-old doll
that was discontinued over 20 years ago?
She also does a fundraiser
by showing the 1931 "Frankenstein".
They don't even show
90-year-old movies in LA,
the movie capital of the country,
there's no way you're
selling out a full-house
for a "Frankenstein"
screening in New Jersey.
Jake even compares Chucky to
Teddy Ruxpin at one point.
Teddy Ruxpin was an actual
animatronic doll from the '80s,
who, similar to the Good Guy doll,
had his own cartoon series.
I think the Good Guy
doll in "Child's Play"
is inspired 50% by Teddy Ruxpin
and 50% by the My Buddy doll,
which I've already talked about
in my "'Child's Play' Things You Missed".
I get that Jake is a retro doll collector,
but there's no way he'd know
about Teddy Ruxpin, come on.
Also, interesting side note.
When I was searching for
clips to show on this video,
I came across this Teddy
Ruxpin commercial from 1985
where a scientist tries
to bring the doll to life,
like "Frankenstein".
I don't think that's necessarily
why they chose "Frankenstein"
as the movie featured
in episode seven and eight,
but I'll get into that when we
get to the end of the season.
My main point is the only reason
that the kids in the show
know about '80s stuff
is because the creators of
the franchise are older now
and they're putting in references to media
that influenced them.
Despite all of this, though,
Junior does not recognize
Jennifer Tilly from "Bound".
- Aren't you a little
young to have seen "Bound"?
- Anyway, Devon gets
bored in his hospital room
and decides to do some research on Chucky.
This picture of Tiffany is
literally just a screenshot
from "Bride of Chucky".
Like there's no reason
that this should canonically
exist on the internet.
They do this a lot in "Saw" so
I won't dwell on it too much,
but it always bothers me
that they can just use another picture
or make something in Photoshop
or just take a picture
of the younger actress
playing that same character
who is literally in this
season in a flashback.
But before we get to that flashback,
there's an even earlier flashback
of Charles Lee Ray's time at
the foster home as a teenager.
He looks after some of the younger kids
and they role play "Peter Pan",
a story about a magical
boy who lives in Neverland,
a place where children stay young forever
and they never have to listen
to anyone about anything
'cause it's all been done
and it's all been said.
They're the coolest kids and
they take what they can get.
It's interesting to me
that even at this point
Charles had this desire for eternal youth,
because that's basically
what he achieved in 1988
by transferring his soul into
the body of a Good Guy doll
forever giving him the form of a child.
Charles leads the kids to stumble upon
the body of the janitor, who
he refers to as Captain Hook,
and everyone runs away except for one boy,
who we later found out to be Eddie Caputo,
the man who is supposed to
be Charles's getaway driver
the night he was killed in
the opening of "Child's Play".
But back in the present,
Lexy and Jake are
searching the burned house
for the remnants of Chucky.
- What are you waiting for?
- I don't know where your room is.
- Bet he's the only boy in
the school who can say that.
- Oh!
- A detective comes by, discovers Chucky,
and refers to him as an ugly f***ing doll.
I think this is a callback
to the woman who finds Chucky
in the elevator back in the
original "Child's Play".
- Ugly doll.
- Before long I'm pretty
sure every single moment
from the original movie
will have come back
as some kind of Easter egg or reference
if they keep this series up.
Like, for example, how in the original
Andy wears Good Guys pajamas;
and in the show we eventually come across
the pink soccer ball kid
and he's wearing overalls
on top of a striped shirt.
His outfit resembles the Good Guys outfit,
but the colors are different.
And now is the perfect time to tell you
that you can buy this mer--
when the detective brings
Chucky back to Caroline,
he gets distracted by food
and eats a powdered donut
right over the killer doll.
The result is white powder
falling down onto Chucky.
And I'm pretty sure this is no accident,
as this is kind of a running
theme in the franchise.
The snow in "Child's Play",
the fluff in "Curse of Chucky",
then more snow in "Cult of Chucky".
They're constantly recreating
that wintery image.
Given that we're in a
hospital on this episode,
there are obviously gonna
be a lot of callbacks
to "Cult of Chucky", which
similarly takes place
in a mental hospital.
- God, I love hospitals.
- We know you do, Chucky.
But we can't forget that
there's also a hospital scene
in the original.
It's definitely a familiar territory.
So Chucky knows just where
to find some dangerous items.
- You might feel a little prick.
- This one actually comes from the poster
for "Cult of Chucky".
Although I don't think it's
ever actually said in the movie.
Jake and Lexy eventually
decide to see what Devon knows
about the Lakeshore Strangler
and he brings up a good point.
- He never really strangled anyone.
I mean, he was more of
like a mangler or a--
- Devon!
- This is before Devon finds out
that the legend of the cursed Chucky doll
is more than an urban legend,
because we have seen Chucky as a doll
strangle people on several occasions.
- Nothin' like his strangulation
to get the circulation going.
- But the fact that Devon
is the one to bring up
this point about strangling,
it might be a dark foreshadowing
as it would be his own mom
who is strangled by Chucky
later in the story.
Meanwhile, Jake, still a prime suspect
for the recent murders, is
interrogated by Detective Evans.
Pretty sure you need a
parent or a guardian present
to question a minor, Mrs. Evans.
Lucky for both of them, I guess,
they're interrupted by a
disturbance from Caroline's room.
Chucky had pulled the plug on this machine
giving her oxygen, which I
find it very hard to believe
that a device like this
wouldn't have any form
of battery backup, but
everyone freaks out,
especially Mrs. Cross.
I'm pretty sure we're
supposed to get the idea
that she's in a panic,
because they keep playing
the same audio of her saying,
"Please hurry."
- Please hurry. Please
hurry, please hurry.
- She sounds like you guys
trying to get me to finish this video.
Another common request I get
is people asking me to
make more "Saw" content.
I will at some point, but you
don't have to wait that long
because there are a couple of
"Saw" Easter eggs right here
in the next episode of Chucky.
(text thuds)
(sinister music)
The fifth episode would be
titled "Little Little Lies".
It starts a trend of episode
names that parody other works.
In this case, the show "Big Little Lies"
or perhaps the book that it's based on.
Chucky once again proclaims
his love of hospitals
as he swims around in a
dump of discarded needles.
This isn't the first time
that I've talked about someone
rummaging through a needle pit
as this is also something
that happens in "Saw II".
Ever since "Scream" first came
out and started the trend,
Chucky has followed suit by referencing
as many other popular horror
properties as possible.
But I believe this is the first "Saw"
reference for the Chuck.
We wouldn't have to wait
long for the second.
At the Hotel Hackensack
later in this episode,
we see a bald guy in a white t-shirt
lying face down in a puddle.
He looks exactly like John Kramer
when we see him in "Saw" one.
A few days later, class
is back in session.
And in science, the lesson is about biotic
and abiotic factors.
In other words, living
and non-living elements
of our ecosystem.
It seems appropriate
because Jake, Lexy, and Devon's
biggest hurdle right now
is getting people to realize
that the Chucky doll is actually alive,
which makes "Chucky" episode five
kinda feel like "Harry
Potter" number five,
but that's definitely a coincidence.
Given that Chucky's face
got melted in the fire,
Nathan gets Caroline a new Good Guy doll.
- Hi, I'm Tommy.
- This is another callback
to "Child's Play 2",
where Andy's foster parents
happen to have a Good
Guy doll named Tommy,
which Chucky buries in the backyard.
There are 50 different
names for Good Guy dolls
and Chucky and Tommy are two of them.
That evening, there's a lightning storm.
If you've been with the
Chucky franchise for a while,
you know what this means.
But if you're new, you may
not realize this is a clue
that the doll Jake,
Devon, and Lexy destroy
is no longer the real Chucky.
Ever since the first movie,
the sign that Chucky
has transferred his soul
into a new body is the
appearance of storm clouds
and a great strike of lightning.
Part of a ritual called
the Damballa Chant.
Over at the Wheeler house,
Junior's dad is working
on getting him a trainer
for cross-country nationals.
- [Logan] In a week or two
we're gonna have you
back out there runnin'.
I even got you a trainer.
That guy Dobbs. The best.
- We never see or meets Dobbs
so it feels oddly specific
that he's mentioned by name.
I'm gonna go out on a limb here
and say that this might be a
reference to a movie character.
Our "Child's Play" from 1988
was not the first movie
called "Child's Play".
In 1972, a mystery film called
"Child's Play" was released
and it was based off a
play of the same name.
The main character is
named at Joseph Dobbs.
Maybe this is a reference to that.
Also. I just wanna add.
I love the implication that Lexy's mom
doesn't know how to operate the dishwasher
without the maid around.
No surprise there.
This is the episode where we finally see
where Chucky first met Tiffany.
He walks over to her table and asks.
- Hey, Red. What's new?
- She's not the only one to be called Red.
In "Seed of Chucky", Jennifer
Tilly pursues a relationship
with the rapper producer
known as Redman and says--
- Thank you, Mr. Man.
Oh, could I call you Red?
- In Tiffany's case, however,
Charles may be calling her
red because she has red hair.
You just can't really tell
because there's a red light cast on her
in both of the scenes she's
in before she goes blonde.
We jump forward to present day,
where Chucky and Tiffany
are back making love
in the same hotel, both
in different bodies
than they were in the '80s.
That's not me saying that they got fat,
like they're literally
in different bodies.
But in reality, Tiffany did
happen to gain some weight
and Chucky criticizes her eating habits.
So she fires back at him with one of her
"My mother always told me" catchphrases,
something that she's been pulling out
since we first met her in Bride.
There's another sneaky
reference to "Bride of Chucky"
as Principal McVey greets
everybody coming into the assembly
at the school auditorium.
- Hey, can we expect those famous
everything but the sink cookies this year?
Great.
- Not knowing what everything
but the sink cookies are,
I looked it up and discovered
it's the name of a recipe
created by Martha Stewart,
the TV personality who Tiffany idolized
throughout "Bride of
Chucky"..... until the end.
- **** Martha Stewart!
- [Zac] I noticed that each
of the seats in the auditorium
have labels on them.
I'm guessing this is
just the way things were
at the location where they filmed this,
but I couldn't help but
notice that one of them says
"Barber's Chair".
One of Chucky's victims
in "Child's Play 3"
was killed in a barber's chair.
However, I'm gonna call this a coincidence
because all of the other
chairs have labels on them
and none of them have any
significant meaning to me
as a Chucky franchise viewer.
Thought it would just be
a fun thing to mention.
Much like how I think it's fun
that they had the balls to put a meme song
in a "Chucky" episode.
This guy's going viral.
Get this on the trending page.
Don't worry, I blurred it out.
Episode six is called "Cape Queer",
a parody of the movie "Cape Fear",
which Devon can be seen watching
and he takes inspiration from.
And we are finally reintroduced
to the man himself, Andy Barclay.
So in the last episode, Nica was told
that the date is November eighth.
This episode looks to be on the next day.
We don't know for sure,
but we can kind of assume
that it's the next day
which would be November
9th, Andy's birthday.
Andy was first introduced
on his sixth birthday,
reintroduced the day
before his 31st birthday,
and now we would be meeting
him again on his 39th birthday.
Andy and Kyle go to investigate a house
where they suspect Chucky might be.
And when this little
girl brings out her doll,
you can see the burnt fingers
on Chucky's right hand.
This tells us that this
is the very same doll
from "Cult of Chucky",
which Nika had Dr. Foley
hold a lighter up to
in an attempt to prove
that it was just a doll,
which of course was unsuccessful.
This means that Andy and
Kyle are still hunting down
the remaining fragments of Chucky's soul.
A male-female soul hunting
duo? Sounds familiar.
At the end of Cult, we can assume
that buzz cut and no bod are dead,
leaving hot hands, Nica
Chucky, and cope Chucky.
But hot hands is taken out in episode six,
which leaves just Nica
Chucky and cope Chucky,
who is presumably the
one that belongs to Jake.
Not that any of this matters
because they'll never
kill the last Chucky off,
but I just find it fun to sort out.
With Jake's name mostly cleared,
the police arrest Mrs. Fairchild...
in the middle of her science class?
They couldn't have just asked
her for a word in the hall
instead of arresting her in
front of all of the students?
Especially when they don't even have proof
that Ms. Fairchild is guilty?
I'm really starting to doubt
Detective Evan's abilities as a cop.
This girl's just happy winter
break came early this year.
I love how the editor tried to get away
with using the same hotel exterior
in episode five and six by
just putting a car there
in episode five.
Anyway, we come in on Tiffany
who is busy trying to close a suitcase
filled with human remains.
In "Bride of Chucky",
she had the same problem
with her storage chest,
which accidentally still had
Damien's hair sticking out
shortly before she got help
loading it into her car.
She gets frustrated
with Chucky and screams.
- Get your leg off my suitcase!
- Before chopping down with a cleaver.
And although she wasn't
actually attempting
to chop Nica's leg off,
this is kind of a
preview of things to come
because she does later end up
removing all of Nica's limbs
so that she can't get away
even if Chucky takes over her body.
I have more to say about this,
but I'll save it for later.
This episode also features
more flashback material.
And this one scene shows
off the origin of not three,
but four iconic elements
that fans have come to love
in the Chucky franchise.
(thunder rumbles)
(thunder clasp)
(sinister music)
In a flashback to 1987,
we see a younger Chucky and
Tiffany purchasing a Pontiac.
And when I say purchasing,
I mean, obtaining
This car is not a big part of the series.
It's not something you would
necessarily even notice,
but I like that they
included it in the scene
because Tiffany still has
it over a decade later
in "Bride of Chucky".
But it's never driven because
she turns into a doll.
We do see it again,
though, in "Cult of Chucky"
as the car that Chucky and Tiffany
make their getaway from the asylum in.
The color is described as
Coronado Red, which Tiffany loves,
probably 'cause it'll be less noticeable
when blood gets on it.
This also marks the first
time chronologically
that she uses her signature
weapon, her nail file.
But there's even more that
originates from this scene.
Roll it.
(text swooshes)
- It's a stunning automobile.
And a true classic
never goes out of style.
- What'd you say?
- The car wasn't the
only thing Chucky stole,
as he would also claim this line
as one of his many catch phrases.
- A true classic never goes out of style.
- Then he makes this clarification.
- [Charles] Technically,
it isn't even an antique.
- (chuckles) Well, sure it is.
It's vintage and retro.
- This calls all the way
back to, well, episode one,
where Jake uses this distinction
between vintage and retro
to haggle the price of the doll.
- What's the difference?
- About 10 bucks.
- Then after stealing the
car, Chucky kicks back
and reads from "The
Ultimate Book of Voodoo",
which presumably marks the beginning
of his interest in voodoo in
order to transfer his soul
into another body to beat death.
Back in the present, Tiffany tests to see
if Chucky or Nica is in control
by asking about their
honeymoon in Niagara.
Nica wasn't there for this,
so she's calling her
bluff in the poker game
while simultaneously calling
her bluff in the conversation
in the situation.
After knocking Nica out,
she picks up the keys to her
recently purchased house.
And of course, she's got the same car
and she's buying Chucky's old house.
I guess she's basking in the nostalgia,
but I'm not sure how to feel about her
not being goth anymore.
This is goth erasure.
#stopgotherasure.
If you look on the For Sale sign,
you'll see that the realtor's
name is Gladys Kravitz.
She shares a name with a character
from the 1960s sitcom "Bewitched".
Her character is
portrayed by Alice Pierce,
who shares a name with Alice
Pierce from "Curse of Chucky".
What is the reason for these characters
being named in connection
with "Bewitched"?
It's not really clear.
I'm guessing Don Mancini is just a fan.
He actually brought up the show once
in an interview with Forbes.
Around this time, Andy and
Kyle are in Richmond, Virginia
where Jake and his friends
make contact with them
and Andy welcomes them to
the lucky group of survivors
who know about Chucky.
Just for fun, that group would
include Andy, Karen Barclay,
Detective Mike Norris,
Detective Jack Santos,
Kyle, Kristin DeSilva,
Ronald Tyler, Major Ellis,
Jesse and Jade Miller, and Nica Pierce.
Let me know if you can
think of any others.
One character who is not
so lucky is Bree Wheeler.
She gets knocked out of the window
of a high-rise building by Chucky,
a direct callback to the
first kill of the first movie.
Both of these characters are
the main character's aunt.
We also saw an aunt character fall
from a great height in Curse.
I guess if you have a niece
or nephew in the series,
get ready to take some fall damage.
The song that plays during the
scene is called "Trampoline".
I guess Bree really
could've used one here.
There are a couple more
"Child's Play"-esque
references that evening
when the trio sets a trap
for Chucky in Logan's house.
Chucky gets around this by
sneaking in through the chimney,
thereby leaving tiny
footprints in the dust
near the fireplace, just like
he did in the spilled flour
back in Karen Barclay's kitchen.
He proceeds to turn on
all the gas in the house,
the same tactic that he
used in Eddie Caputo's house
before blowing it up.
I don't know if it would
actually work this time
because he left the flame on.
I'm pretty sure it's
only when the gas is on
without a flame when you have to worry.
Episode six ends with
the death of Devon's mom.
And with the body count
really piling up now,
the intro of episode seven
fittingly shows the "Chucky" logo
made up of the gravestones
of many of the victims
of the Chucky franchise.
They aren't just victims
from this season, though;
they're victims from the
entire history of Chucky.
They include Howard
Fitzwater AKA Damien Baylock,
Tiffany's goth boyfriend
from "Bride of Chucky";
Sarah Pierce, Nica's mother
from "Curse of Chucky";
Grace Poole, Andy's social
worker from "Child's Play 2";
Tony Gardner, the movie's
special effects guy
from "Seed of Chucky", who, by the way,
is also the actual puppeteer
and a producer for the franchise.
His appearance in "Seed of
Chucky" is actually a cameo.
Sean Peyton, the police
officer who is stabbed
with the syringes in episode four.
Eddie Caputo, Charles Lee Ray's accomplice
and getaway driver in "Child's Play".
Warren Kincaid, the police
officer and father of Jade
in "Bride of Chucky".
Redman, the rapper/movie
producer from "Seed of Chucky".
Francis Martinez, we can only assume
that this is Father Frank
from "Curse of Chucky".
Frank is sometimes used
as a nickname for Francis
and he was Hispanic, so the
last name Martinez kind of fits.
Philip Simpson, the foster
father from "Child's Play 2",
and Joanne Simpson,
the foster mother from "Child's Play 2".
Due to the stress of losing his wife
and all of the strange circumstances
of the things going on around
him, Logan takes to drinking.
When he gets up, we get a
clear look at the bottle
of Kentucky bourbon that he's working on.
If we go all the way back to episode one
and bring up the lights a little,
this is the same alcohol bottle
that his brother Lucas was drinking from.
I think the show does this to show
that he too now has reached rock-bottom,
just like his brother, and
neither one deals with this
in a healthy way.
Shortly after this, Junior meets Chucky.
I would think that this would be proof
that Lexy wasn't lying to
him back at the auditorium.
Roll it.
(text swooshes)
- Jake's doll Chucky was
alive and he killed his dad
and he killed Oliver and
the cop at the hospital
and your housekeeper too,
and he wouldn't stop killing
so we broke him into
pieces and now he's dead.
So everyone can stop worrying about it.
- But, I don't know, maybe
since Junior didn't believe her,
he just forgot or maybe
he just doesn't care
because he's in a lot of pain
and he's gonna become evil regardless.
As I mentioned before,
the climax of the season
revolves around this charity screening
of James Whale's "Frankenstein".
I see this as kind of the
completion of an analogy.
In "Bride of Chucky",
we saw Tiffany watching
"Bride of Frankenstein"
so it's only natural that in "Chucky"
she would be watching "Frankenstein".
In the evening,
Tiffany brings a prepared
meal by the house.
- It's Swedish meatballs.
- Which if you remember back to Bride,
it was Chucky's favorite food.
So it's very possible
that she was actually bringing
this dish over for him,
not for Junior's dad.
I do wonder if she
obliged to do the dishes
this time, though.
Jake, who was attempting
to run away from home,
finds himself in a chance encounter
with an entirely new Good Guy doll
and Logan would become
the victim of a kill
that looks very familiar.
(sinister music)
(thunder rumbles)
- As Jake is trying to make
like a Fountains of Wayne lyric
and get out of Hackensack,
he notices a delivery man
carrying a Good Guy doll and
buys it off of him for $350.
It must've been a pretty crappy job
if he's willing to lose it for 350 bucks.
This one is named Billy
and appears not to be possessed
by Charles Lee Ray yet.
The name Billy could be
an homage to Billy Boyd,
the actor who voices
Glen in "Seed of Chucky"
or perhaps it's another "Saw" reference.
Billy the Puppet is one of
the only horror movie dolls
who is as iconic as Chucky is.
Or it could just be a random
name. In any event, we now know
six of the 50 possible Good Guy names
and I will not rest
until we know them all.
With the knowledge of where this doll
was supposed to be delivered,
Jake returns to Hackensack
to save his friends
from whatever is brewing.
I'm comfortable referring
to Lexy and Devon
as his friends at this point,
but Lexy actually refers
to them as his family.
- What family?
- Me, Devon, the family you chose.
- Which I get it, character development.
Lexy has a heart now.
She's doing the whole Dom Toretto meme.
- [Dom] I got family.
- But I still find it funny
that this is less than a month
from her publicly making a
mockery of his dad's death
and him trying to have her killed.
Contrary to that, there's
also an interesting
wardrobe choice in this scene.
Before I noted how Lexy and
Junior wore matching hoodies.
But as their relationship deteriorated,
she no longer stayed in sync with him.
Now she's matching with Jake.
Hers is a different color,
but they're both wearing
the same plaid pattern.
I don't think this is
alluding to a relationship
because Jake is stated
to be gay, not bisexual.
But who knows?
There is that line from
his father in episode one
that suggests that Jake
doesn't know what he is yet.
In any event, Jake is in time
to save his chosen family,
but isn't quick enough to
save his actual family.
In Logan's death scene,
Chucky's head rotates around to greet him.
This was originally a
reference to "The Exorcist",
but it's since become a Chucky thing.
It's happened in nearly every
entry since "Bride of Chucky".
Junior is the one to
take his dad out, though.
And he does it by beating him
down with the Chucky doll.
The scene serves as a reminder
of the ending of "Seed of Chucky",
where Tiffany beats
her nanny over the head
with the Tiffany doll.
This doesn't seem to
hurt Chucky very much,
which begs the question
of if Jake and Lexy's test
to see if their dolls
were alive by beating them
would've even done any good.
It seems like fire is the
only thing painful enough
to make him scream.
In an attempt to rescue Devon,
Lexy calls them an Uber.
- [Jake] Where's the Uber?
- Four minutes.
- I got kinda nervous when I heard that,
but then I remembered that
Ubers are only dangerous
in the reboot.
After Chucky sees Junior
take out his father,
we learned that this
was his goal all along.
- You had no idea how hard
it's been getting one,
you little sh*ts, to step
the **** up and play.
- It seems like Chucky is
talking about his Super Bowl line
way back in episode two.
- It's the Super Bowl of slaughter.
- This turns out to be the
final step of Chucky's ritual
and the rest of his cult finally wakes up.
But before he can rejoin
them in episode eight,
An Affair to Dismember,
which is a parody of the 1957
film "An Affair to Remember",
Andy shows up at the Wheeler household
to get in his rival's way.
So Chucky just decides to hide.
- He had a gun.
I hate guns.
They're like my Achilles'
heel along with axes, fire,
and those big industrial size fans.
- To quote the Chuck himself,
these are all actual examples.
He was killed by an axe in Seed,
he was thrown in the fireplace in one,
and he was chopped up by a
big industrial fan in three,
which, as you probably know,
happens after most of
the movie takes place
at Andy's military school.
I find it interesting
how Chucky has turned the
tables against Andy since then.
Near the end of "Child's Play 3",
Andy is essentially backed by an army
and Chucky has to flee.
Now, Chucky is the one
with an army behind him.
There might even be a reference
to this in the dialogue.
- We're gonna party like it's 1999.
- According to my calculations
in the Chucky timeline video,
1999 was the year that
"Child's Play 3" took place.
So by saying this, he's essentially saying
that they're going to kill Andy.
The new recruits have a few
questions about the operation.
- Is there an age limit
on potential victims?
- Well, let's just say nobody
under the age of five or six.
Fair enough?
- Poor Andy was six years old
in the original "Child's Play"
so I guess he just missed the cutoff.
As Tiffany brings down
some cookies to the party,
we hear the song "Sick
Bubblegum" by Rob Zombie.
I wanted to point this
out for two reasons.
One, Rob Zombie also did
the song "Living Dead Girl"
for "Bride of Chucky",
which is essentially the
theme song of Tiffany.
So it's fitting that she'd be
listening to some Rob Zombie
in her own house.
Two, earlier in this video,
I talked about a whole lot
of "Halloween" references
present in this season
and Rob Zombie technically
is a "Halloween" director.
It's not all fun and glam metal, though,
as things would take a darker turn
when Chucky orders Junior
to kill Nica under suspicion
that Tiffany is developing
feelings towards her.
The scene has an unexpected outcome
when Tiffany turns and kills Chucky,
or at least this particular
incarnation of Chucky.
It calls back to that
flashback scene in the '80s
when Charles Lee Ray and
Tiffany first hooked up
and it looks like he's gonna kill Tiffany
but then unexpectedly turns
and slashes up the other chick.
So their relationship began
with an unexpected change of allegiance,
and now it's deteriorating with one.
But then again, Chucky
and Tiffany's relationship
has literally always been toxic
so who knows if this
really means anything.
We flashback to the '80s
again to see more of the night
that Charles originally
transferred his soul
out of his human body.
After a fight, Tiffany can
be seen calling the police
and she asked for Mike Norris,
who, as we know from the original movie,
is the one to kill Charles
Lee Ray at the toy store.
So in a way, Chucky and
Tiffany were each responsible
for killing each other's
original human form
because nothing says love like
having your partner executed.
I saw some people complaining
that having Tiffany called
the cops on Chucky in 1988
retcon's the flashback
from "Curse of Chucky".
But if you actually watch that scene,
the new information doesn't
actually change anything.
Chucky accuses Sarah
Pierce of ratting him out.
- You told him about us?
- But she never actually
acknowledges that accusation.
- There is no us.
- Talking about the
character relationships
really makes me wonder if Tiffany knows
who Nica actually is.
She obviously knows that she's
part of the Pierce family
that Chucky brutalized in
2013, we see that much in Cult,
but I don't know if she knows
that Nica is the daughter of a woman
that Chucky tried to have an affair with.
It seems unlikely that
Tiffany would develop feelings
for the daughter of her biggest rival
for Charles's affection.
Anyway, Andy Barclay gets there
a little bit too late for the party,
but he is at least in time to save Devon,
who is still captive there.
- Another goddamn head.
Why not?
- Of course this is a reference to Cult
where Andy keeps the head of
a Chucky doll in captivity.
This is just one of
many, many, many examples
I've brought up throughout
this video of callbacks
to the original seven Chucky movies.
And I've already discussed
how the spotlight
was more on "Child's
Play 2" than the others.
What happens next is
another example of that.
Only this time,
these circumstances are
a little bit different.
(sinister music)
(tense music)
After being abandoned at the gas station,
Kyle still manages to
make her way to Hackensack
where she protects Jake and
Lexy from the Chucky doll
at Lexy's house.
Then, for their own
safety, she drugs them.
Yes, two kids that she's never met
and she roofies them in
the first 10 minutes.
And I love how she doesn't
even attempt to tell them,
"Hey, you guys should just stay here.
It's too dangerous.
Don't worry, Andy and I are
gonna save your friend."
No, she just goes straight to the roofies.
Why is this her first idea?
I mean, why does she
even have roofies on her
when she gets locked out of the car?
Not a good look, Kyle. Not a good look.
She makes her way to the
Ray house on Sherwood Lane
and unknowingly sets off the bomb,
leaving Jake and Lexy to believe
that her, Andy, and Devon
were inside during the blast.
But they quickly learned
that Devon got out alive.
The next day is the
Frankenstein Benefit Screening,
where Tiffany, or as the public
knows her Jennifer Tilly,
announces that these
Chucky dolls will be given
to children in need, for some reason.
Seeing the yellow boxes
stacked up like this
should be a familiar sight
to anyone who's seen "Child's Play 2".
It's a reminder of the maze
of Good Guy doll products
inside the Play Pals factory
at the conclusion of the film.
This is an appropriate
time for this callback
because what we're about to see
would have history repeating itself.
Lexy finds Junior in the back
hallway at the movie theater
with Chucky riding on
his back at knifepoint
and she gives chase.
This is just like the scenario
at the end of "Child's Play 2",
where Andy was the one
being threatened by Chucky
and Kyle was the blonde girl giving chase.
Even the colors feel nostalgic here.
The back section of the movie
theater is red and yellow,
just like the maze at the factory.
I probably don't need to point this out,
but since we're past the point
and we're lengthening this video
a little bit matters at all,
you may have noticed that what we see
in the movie "Frankenstein"
corresponds to what's
happening in our story.
For example, we see Chucky
sitting next to Caroline,
his new best friend to the end,
and on screen we see the scene
where the monster befriends a little girl.
I'm not gonna point them all out because,
again, I think this is pretty obvious.
But if you didn't pick up on it,
it's something that you can
look out for on your next watch.
And I know I keep coming back to this,
but once again it's the same
concept seen in "Scream"
where the characters
are watching "Halloween"
and it's intercut with similar scenarios
going on in "Scream".
By the way, Caroline is painted
to be a complete sociopath
who continues to sit
there watching the movie
even as everyone around
her is being killed
and pays no mind to her dad who
has slumped over next to her
as Jake and Devon tried
to get her out there.
I think the creators
realized this in editing
and tried to add this line.
- [Caroline] But what about daddy?
- You can just tell it
was dialogue replacement.
By the way, Chucky's method
of murder in the movie theater
is to hide underneath the
seats and stab up through them.
It's the same thing he tried to do
with Mike Norris's car seat in 1988.
Behind the screen, Junior
describes how Chucky changed him
and taught him to be a man.
I noticed that he's wearing a hoodie
similar to the one that
he had matching with Lexy,
but this one is different.
It's green.
Junior is no longer the boy he was
when he and Lexy split up.
His short time with Chucky
has really changed him.
Jake ends up in a physical altercation
with his original Chucky
in the movie theater
where Chucky's impressive strength,
relative to his small
size, is finally explained.
- You're nothing against the power,
the great almighty Damballa.
- Which is kind of different
from how he pronounced the
great voodoo entity's name
in the other movies.
- Ade due Damballa.
- But don't worry, it's not
like I made a whole video
analyzing the history of Damballa
where I took special care to pronounce it
and how they pronounced it in the movies.
- You dare defy the almighty Damballa?
- Yeah, that doesn't bother me at all.
Jake defeats Chucky using his bare hands,
putting him in the same camp as Andy,
who pulled Chucky apart with his own hands
at the end of "Cult".
I think this means that Jake
is symbolically taking up the mantle
as one of Chucky's greatest
rivals alongside Andy.
It's something that we've
seen time and time again
in this era of requels.
The torch being passed to
the younger generation.
We see similar moments in other movies.
New characters taking the
reins from old characters.
Luke Skywalker, Laurie Strode, Jigsaw,
and Sidney Prescott.
It seems like Jake gets
especially offended
when Chucky calls his
relationship with Devon gay.
- Oh, that is so gay.
- Watch your f***in' mouth.
That's my boyfriend you're talking about.
- Can someone explain this to me?
Like, is it still
considered to be offensive
to be called gay if you're actually gay?
'Cause if a gay person called me straight,
I wouldn't be offended
and I'd just be like,
"Yeah, accurate.
Let me get your sister's number."
Despite defeating this Chucky,
there's still a whole truck of Chuck
about to go out to the
children of America.
This is a US→X truck,
the same fictional shipping company
that delivers all of the
dolls in the Curse-Seed arc.
And Andy hijacks this truck.
So he's no longer playing the victim.
He's no longer the recipient
of Chucky's terror.
He's now in the driver's seat.
However, we forgot about one thing.
Remember this Tiffany doll
that we saw momentarily
at the end of "Cult"?
So she's also gotten multiple incarnations
running around at once.
And just like in Bride where
she was first introduced,
she's gonna be responsible for ensuring
that the Chucky dolls reach
their intended destination.
And she's gonna do so by
pointing a gun at the driver.
As always, that was originally
from "Child's Play 2"
where Chucky held Kyle at knifepoint
and made her drive him around.
Same situation.
The male and female
characters are not swapped.
The answer about what happens to Andy
and the truckload of dolls
is left as a cliffhanger this season.
But we do see the next step
in Tiffany and Nica's relationship.
In order to prevent Chucky
from regaining control of Nica
and potentially using it to attack her,
Tiffany has amputated all of Nica's limbs.
Obviously this has less
to do with practicality
and more to do with Tiffany
being the most insane character.
But it's hard to imagine that
Nica is gonna be able to do
much of anything next
season in her current state.
I'm guessing she'll be
transferring her soul
into the body of a doll
or perhaps into the body
of Hollywood actress
Fiona Dourif before long.
And our season one comes
to a close in the cemetery,
where Jake, Lexy, and Devon
would visit the graves
of those that were lost.
The season started with Jake
listening to Devon's podcast,
Hackenslash and it would come full circle
as we hear the latest
edition of that show.
- [Devon] How do we stand
the chance against an enemy
who disguises himself as our friend?
- Back in "Child's Play",
Chucky disguised himself
as a Good Guy doll
and became Andy's best friend to the end.
But now that phrase has
taken a new meaning.
This time Chucky learned to manipulate
their actual friend, Junior.
I believe this is also the
first time in the entire show
that Jake isn't wearing
that stupid necklace
with the skull or doll
head or whatever it is.
I think this represents
his change as a character.
In the beginning, he doesn't have friends
and he spent all of his
time collecting dolls
and making art out of them.
Now, he has real people in his life.
At the very end, we see
that they're being watched
and this person puts their
gloved hand on a tree,
which is our only clue about
this person's identity.
In episode seven, Kyle bought
two pairs of leather gloves
for herself and Andy at
the gas station mart.
Then in episode eight,
there's an explosion at the
old Ray house on Sherwood Lane
and we're led to believe that
those left inside perished,
this includes Devon, Andy, and Kyle.
We later find out that
Devon and Andy were okay,
but according to this headline
in the Hackensack post
there were fatalities
reported in the explosion.
We're left to assume that that means
that Kyle didn't make it.
When Andy later hijacks the truck,
we do see him wearing the
gloves but then he drives away,
presumably still a hostage
of the Tiffany doll.
This leads me to believe
that the hand on the tree
is actually Kyle.
And the fatality reported in the post
was actually referring to the remains
of the decapitated Chucky
left in the building.
If the remaining pieces
were badly charred,
police may have assumed
that this was a baby
caught in the explosion.
So I think this is Kyle, mostly
because it's hard to believe
that they'd bring her back
and then just have her
die off screen like that.
While that may be the end of
the narrative for season one,
we're not done, because I've
gotta talk about the epilogue.
The scene features
Chucky lounging fireside
and directly addressing the audience
about the literary themes
explored in "Chucky" season one.
This is yet another
parallel to "Frankenstein",
more specifically "Bride of Frankenstein",
which features a character
insert for Mary Shelley,
the author of the novel,
in an intro scene where she sits fireside
and explains the moral of the story
before the narrative actually starts.
If you're a fan of my channel,
you may remember me actually making a joke
in my "'Bride of Chucky'
Things You Missed"
about how they should have
done a similar fireside chat
with Chucky creator Don Mancini.
So I got a huge kick out
of this epilogue scene,
especially this line.
Roll it.
(text swooshes)
- The eternal questions
explored by authors,
such as Austin, Shakespeare, Mancini.
- Kinda makes me wonder if Don Mancini
has been watching a little CZsWorld.
Kinda curious if he rang that death bell.
But one horror movie analysis channel
that he's almost definitely been watching
is our friend Dead Meat,
who is most known for
his world's famous show
the Kill Count, where
he counts up the kills
in all your favorite horror movies,
'cause that's exactly
what Chucky does here.
- And speaking of who died,
let's review, shall we?
- We also saw Chucky embrace
the idea of a kill count
during his last confrontation with Jake.
- [Chucky] Eventually they're
gonna forget the names
of everybody who died here tonight.
All they'll remember is the
number of people I killed,
my body count.
- This is something that
we've been seeing more
in the horror genre, the idea
of a built-in kill count.
We saw it in "Us"
and we see it getting
much more attention here
as a full-blown segment
at the end of the season.
I think the challenge
is on for season two,
not only to surpass the 21 kills
racked up over the first season,
but to also break the
record that it just set
for most things you missed.
To find out if season two pulls it off,
make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week.
Ring the death bell and
select all notifications
and I will see you in the next season.
Assuming we both survive.
Now, can anyone remember
the name of the doll
that this show is about?
(upbeat electronic music)